la nueva variante delta está asolando
asia y oceanía que habían luchado
eficazmente contra la pandemia y que
quizá por ello descuidaron la vacunación
de su población hoy encadenan récords
diarios de contagios y muertos ordenan
nuevos encierros o prorrogan los
anteriores
tokio ha tenido que dictar el cuarto
estado de emergencia y prohibir la
afluencia de público a sus estadios
durante los juegos olímpicos en corea
del sur la nueva variante se está
cebando en los jóvenes de entre 20 y 40
años y ha superado por primera vez este
año el millar de contagios diarios
indonesia también ha superado el millar
de casos diarios pero en este caso de
muertos con el sistema sanitario
colapsado más de 60 personas murieron el
pasado fin de semana por falta de
oxígeno en los hospitales
tailandia su creado también el número de
muertos diarios a pesar de que bangkok
cerró bares restaurantes y gimnasios
días atrás y en australia sidney vaya
por su tercera semana de encierro merece
la pena echar un vistazo a china que
desde el inicio de la pandemia ha
dictado
normas que fueron desdeñadas por el
mundo como exageradas y que después tuvo
que adoptar pues bien china la semana
pasada anunció la construcción de un
centro gigantesco para cuarentenas de
viajeros con la nueva variante del está
porque entiende china que los hoteles
que se usaban hasta ahora no son
suficientes para detener la alta
capacidad de transmisión de la nueva
variante